hello everyone and welcome again to the
third webinar in the series of twelve on
berry crop nutrient and soil management
we're very excited about the program we
still have people registering for the
first time we're up to 72 people now if
you have any colleagues or associates
who might be interested in participating
they're still welcome to join us I just
want to do a quick reminder I want to
point out to you in the files box on the
bottom right that the webinar schedule
is there that you can download the
demographics questionnaire that's the
registration form if you haven't filled
that out and emailed it back to me
please do that and then the educator
pretest for interview that who are new
there's a pretest there please fill that
out and also eel it back email it back
to me at MCM for at cornell.edu if you
would like to participate in the webinar
you are able to type comments or
questions into the chat box at the
bottom that's the same place where you
typed in your name in your location
other ways to participate or up on the
top of the screen you'll see a person
with their hand raised there's several
things that you can do you can agree or
disagree raise your hand to indicate you
have a question ask someone to speak
louder or softer to speed up to slow
down to laugh to applaud and all of
those little icons will show up next to
your name in the attendees box
on the bottom left-hand side of the
screen you'll see some web links
northeast ser has its own website and it
has a link there Cornell free fruit
resources berries is also there and then
at the bottom are the webinar archives
if you've missed any of the webinars in
the series they are recorded and you can
listen to the any you've missed by going
to that link ok we're ready to start our
speaker for this week is dr. Marvin
Pritts professor and chair of the
department of horticulture at Cornell
University and our topic is soil
nutrient management he's going to
discuss correction of soil problems
application technology conventional
nutrient sources organic nutrient
sources oh I'm sorry that's next week's
topic liming in pH reductions so now you
know it will be studying next week
marvin was born in southwestern
pennsylvania and got his BS in biology
from Bucknell and his ms in biology from
the University of South Carolina he got
his PhD in horticulture at Michigan
State University working with wild
species of blueberries he came to
Cornell in 1984 as the berry crop
specialist with an appointment in
extension research and teaching Marvin
works primarily with production and pest
management systems and strawberries and
raspberries including food safety issues
and has consulted with berry farmers
throughout the world he became chairman
of the Department of Horticulture in
july 2002 he to reach teaches career
explorations in the plant sciences hands
on horticulture berry crop production
and management and leadership
development for life scientists Marvin
Thank You Kathy and welcome all of you
to the webinar it's a beautiful day here
in New York I hope it's nice where you
are as well what we want to do today is
talk about how to interpret soil test
and the soil tests as we mentioned
before in previous webinars are used
before planting that's where we're
primarily using our soil tests and a
goal of soil testing just to refresh is
to estimate the plant available nutrient
levels in the soil soil tests do not
tell you how much of a particular
nutrient is in the soil they estimate
how much of a particular nutrient in a
soil is available to the plant so the
extractant sort of mimics what a plant
root might have available to them and
since you can't you mimic that perfectly
people come up with these different
extractants to try to imitate what a
plant root might be able to extract from
the soil once those values are obtained
then a recommendation is made to bring
those levels up to some optimum because
we don't want oil nutrients to be
limiting typically plants respond to
soil nutrients in a curve that sort of
looks like a you know it's you get a
rapid response at low levels but as you
get further learning curve the response
that more and more nutrients begins to
level out so
you don't get a response at all and the
goal of soil nutrient testing is
somewhat build up the soil nutrient bank
so there's never a risk of nutrients
being limited but there are some
philosophies of soil testing where you
want to just apply enough to where the
economic gain from an additional
amendment is equal to the cost of the
added amendment so let me just maybe try
to show you that graphically in some
philosophies you want to try to be right
here in the curve where you're just
starting to see a decrease in a response
other philosophies say well we want to
be up here because we don't ever want to
be in a situation where we want to be in
a deficient condition and different
soils labs sort of give you
recommendations based on that philosophy
and probably not surprisingly soils labs
that also sell fertilizers tend to be up
here at the top end and university labs
and all tend to want to be down here
it's a little bit harder with perennial
crops to be in this range here where the
green arrows point out because we don't
often have a chance to go back in
annually and add a little bit of
nutrient to bring us up to where we need
so if you look at recommendations for
annual crops they'll often be down in
this range with very crops and perennial
crops we tend to have to find a happy
medium between here and up here because
we can't go in annually and replenish
very well
so the ideal is somewhere between do we
just can't go in and incorporate the
amount of nutrients we need after years
up so except for sandy soils the
eventual nutrient supply which is how
much is in the soil plus how much we add
as fertilizer should be sufficient for
the life expectancy the planting and
this would be looking at you know maybe
five years your strawberries maybe 10 to
15 for raspberries without having to
come back in and annually apply
phosphorus potassium magnesium calcium
and so forth of course nitrogen we do
apply that annually but that's very
soluble and it can get down into the
root zone very quickly these other
nutrients phosphorus in particular very
difficult to move through the soil
profile so we need to have that
incorporated before we plant that's why
we have to maybe build up a little bit
of a bank particularly for longer lived
crops like raspberries and particularly
blueberries
so whenever these soil tests are done
and recommendations come out every soil
is probably going to give you a slightly
different response curve to the crop of
interest and we can't develop response
curves for every soil type in your state
so we have to make some generalizations
and also the truth of the matter is
these response curves have not been
developed for strawberries and
raspberries and blueberries on all
different soil types oftentimes the
agronomists have done these things for
field crops but not so much for food
crops so guess a point here is that
we're making educated guesses about how
very crops respond often based on the
response to some of these agronomic
crops we know a little bit more about a
one approach that's often used is to
find an agronomic crop that has a
similar response to a fruit crop but
where there's a lot more data for and
use that it's sort of a foundation for
some of the soil testing recommendations
then the good example would be alfalfa
which tends to have the same sort of a
response to nutrients in the soil and
soil types as do strawberries and
raspberries you know alfalfa is a
perennial strawberries and raspberries
are perennial they have a about the same
rooting depth they have a same pH
requirement for soil for optimal growth
so those are oftentimes use as a basis
or recommendation first people do
nutrient response curves for some of
these and this is an example actually
from strawberry and this is looking at
nitrogen and these are looking at
various rates of nitrogen fertilizer on
plants and this isn't a this is in a
liquid form so it's not quite easily to
convert to pounds per acre but the point
is at low nutrient levels you don't get
much of a response but as you move up
you get a higher higher response but
then the curve kind of flattens out
if we look at leaf area we fertilize it
more and more nitrogen you know the
leaves love it and they really expand a
lot and grow a lot but if we look at
yield it's not nearly as responsive to
the increases in nitrogen so that says
okay the optimal rate is probably
somewhere around this 10 n situation
here so we can do these response curves
to some extent and sort of calibrate our
soil test by that so it's not that they
don't exist for Barry crops existence
there's not a lot of those out there to
calibrate on
some recommendations are based on
response curves that are dependent on
the soil type in other words to get a
good recommendation you have to input
the soil type so then the software knows
what soil type that is it can make a
recommendation based on that a Morgan
extracting is a good example of a type
of soil test that is you have to have a
soil type or at least know whether it's
a sandy loam or a loam or silt or a clay
because the response curve and the
extractant is based on that soil type
you have many labs are getting away from
those tests are dependent on soil type
and looking at other tests that that's
less important and the modified Morgan
is one of those tests that is a little
bit less dependent on knowing the type
of soil do you have in there and a lot
of this due to the amount of potassium
that the different extractants pull out
of the soil
but you have to sort of assume that the
soil tests that you're using the
procedures our are good and accurate and
that the recommendations come out are on
target now a question was asked like a
week or so ago about organic versus
conventional recommendations the
recommendations that come out should be
mostly the same whether one's organic or
conventional it's not what's recommended
it should be different it's the amount
in the type of product that's used
that's different so a soil test might
recommend you know 50 pounds of
potassium but the source of that
potassium is what would differ than
between the organic and conventional
grower
there is some difference in amount based
on release rate some organic nutrients
are a little bit more slower to release
their nutrients so you may have to apply
more of that because we release rates
slower but in general it's the total
amount would be the same
so when you get your soil test the most
important adjustment that we usually
make is to soil pH if the soil pH isn't
within the desired range then the
ability to take up nutrients will be
compromised so if you don't have the pH
right you can put on a lot of a certain
nutrient and it might not even get into
the plant because of the pH and you
probably have all seen this in soils
classes back in college but the amount
of nutrient is available to the plant is
very dependent on soil pH and the
optimal range for most crops is a little
bit less than 6 up to about 6.5 and of
course you all know blueberries are the
exception they're down around 4.5 for
the optimum but for most of the plants
that we're dealing with with the berries
and even vegetable crops it's up around
six to six point five because of that
range most of the nutrients are
reasonably available to the plant
now if we have to make an adjustment to
the pH we use sulfur to lower it and
lime to raise it oftentimes in catalogs
and particularly for homeowners you'll
see aluminum sulfate recommended to
lower the pH and we do not recommend
that because aluminum is toxic to plants
at high rates now granted it provides a
rapid change in pH because the sulfur is
already oxidized when it's an aluminum
sulfate form so i could go right to work
and lower that ph almost right away
whereas sulfur takes some time but you
don't want all that aluminum so we don't
recommend that for lowering pH and
changing the soil pH after planting is
extremely slow and difficult that's why
it's so important to do it before
planting at a couple of photos here of
people who have planted and then realize
that their ph is too low and tried to
raise it with lime and you can see it
just makes a real mess in the field it's
really hard to incorporating get that
lime down into the root zone where it
has an impact so if you can mix it in
the soil before you plant it just makes
a world of difference oh that's very
feel the same way how are you going to
work that line down into the soil well
enough to really change the pH around
the root zone where there's new trees
can be taken up better really hard to do
that
so the amount of lime you're going to
apply to the soil to change the pH is
dependent on two things and one is the
difference between the current pH and
your target pH so how big is a gap
between where you want to be and where
you currently are and then the second
thing is something called a cation
exchange capacity or the soil buffering
capacity this is the ability to the soil
to hold on to the cations in the soil
through these exchange sites they're
like negative charges on the soil
particles and it's the ratio of the
cations that are bound to these negative
charges to charges that only have
hydrogen attached to them it's the ratio
of the cations to the hydrogen ions to
determine your pH
this is often called base saturation or
the percent of the exchange sites
occupied by the bases so just think of
it as a like a column the column has a
lot of negative charges on it some of
those charges then attached to
positively charged cations such as
calcium magnesium and potassium those
are the major ones the remainder tend to
be populated with hydrogen ions and the
more hydrogen ions you have the lower
your pH remember pH is the negative log
of the hydrogen ion content or something
like that anyway the higher the ratio of
the hydrogen ions the cation is the more
acid to soil so the more these exchange
sites we have and if we want to change
it and knock some of those hydrogen's
off the exchange site we have to add a
lot more base
the negative charges on our soils arise
from either clay particles or organic
matter those are the sources of the
negative charges so the clay particles
and the organic matter hold on to those
positive charges that are out there so
also have a lot of exchange capacity and
always have a lot of negative charges
are more difficult to adjust the pH so
if you want to knock hydrogen ions off
that exchange sites you have to use a
lot of line but once you make that
adjustment soils that are high and kind
of exchange capacity tend to be more
stable a lot more resistant to change
once you make the change solo are easy
to change but they'll revert back to a
low pH as those calcium and magnesium
potassium ions reach from the soil and
then the hydrogen takes over those
exchange sites and the pH drops again
so reiterate it's easy to raise the pH
of a sandy soil with low organic matter
because sandy soils and low organic
soils have low cation exchange capacity
conversely is hard to lower the pH of a
clay soil having a higher getting in our
content because both clay and organic
matter contribute to these negative
charges in slow
so the amount of sulfur this is just
estimates ballpark estimates to lower
the pH to a desired level of 4.5 depends
the two things we mentioned it depends
on the current pH which is over here
and of course the further we are from
4.5 which our target pH the more sulfur
it will take to lower it and the higher
our kind of exchange capacity the more
software it will take to lower it so in
a sandy soil not much loamy soil with
more negative charges higher cation
exchange capacity it takes more sulfur
and with clays even more sulfur so we're
up in this range here the high ph soil
with heavy soil it's really really hard
to lower that pH 24.5 even with a lot of
software it just takes a huge amount so
oftentimes soils up in here aren't
really suitable for blueberry production
so soil tests attempt to estimate the
amount of lime or software required to
bring the ph to within the desired range
for particular crop and it's based on
this kind of exchange capacity soil
tests do not measure cation exchange
capacity directly in other words it
doesn't go in and directly measure the
amount of negative charges of there and
how many of those negative charges are
populated by hydrogen ions they use
indirect methods to measure that it's an
exact science different procedures are
used in different labs and account
exchange capacity itself vary somewhat
with pH and other factors so guess what
I'm trying to say here is that
oftentimes the lime recommendations we
think of them as being really really
precise but the truth of the matter is
there are estimates they try to put you
in a ballpark but they're not absolutely
precise the kind of exchange capacity
varies with various soils sands of
course have low and loans a little bit
higher and clays have higher and you can
see that reflected into sulfur
recommendations in the previous table
you miss organic matter is sort of
broken down form has very very high
count exchange capacity so that's why
soils high in organic matter require a
lot of sulfur or lime to make
adjustments to them
and we don't want to forget that adding
lime or software to the soil does not
change the pH instantly it takes six
months or longer usually it's dependent
on the size of the particle of the lime
and a sulfur smaller particle sizes
adjust more quickly depends on soil
moisture and dry soils you get very
little very slow oxidation and
conversion takes a lot of time you have
to have adequate soil moisture to make
sure it happens relatively quickly and
in temperature in a winter time not much
happens in the soil that process of
oxidation is a biological process it
requires soil bacteria to make that
conversion so when it's cold there's not
a lot of activity also those bacteria
have to have aeration is a aerobic
process and the soil has to be aerated
so all those things have to happen for
that pH to change after we add our line
of soft
so now let's get into the crux of the
matter here with that background on
interpreting soil test we're going to
look at soil pH the macronutrients and
micronutrients I'm going to run through
seven or eight examples and we'll work
through those and see how a soil test
might interpret those and recommend
those this is just an example of a soil
test we'll look at some of its various
parts they of course the reports that
come back vary a lot from lab to lab but
let's just assume this is sort of a
general recommendation the first thing
you want to look for at least I do is
the pH and we want to look and see
whether that's within the ballpark range
or not and in this case here is for
strawberries the pH range that we use
before we provide a lime recommendations
of between like six and six eight so the
ph's of the net range so we wouldn't
recommend line here sometimes you'll see
a different ph number there and in this
case here there's this thing called
buffer ph in water and people say well
what is that does that mean my ph is too
low because it's less than six well no
in this case here this soil testing lab
is using something called the buffer ph
to estimate count and exchange capacity
and the difference between the buffer ph
and the normal pH in water is an
estimate of the cation exchange capacity
and there's complicated curves and
correlations and so forth but suffice it
to say that the greater the difference
between the pH and a buffer ph the
greater the cation exchange capacity
therefore the slower or harder it's
going to be the change that pH if you
had to change it this case here we won't
have to change it but the situation were
the buffer ph differ greatly from the pH
and water that would imply a high cation
exchange capacity so we don't worry
about that for interpretation we assume
that the software takes that into
account and spits out that lime or
sulfur recommendation based on that
difference and we don't have to worry
about it but it's often shown there so
you can see that it's there it gives you
some sense of when you're comparing
different soils what that cation
exchange capacity difference is if it
print it out directly on the form some
soil tests printed out directly this one
prints out that buffer ph to ph
comparison another thing i like to look
at is the organic matter content i like
to see organic matters you know two
percent or higher this is pretty good
four point six percent it indicates that
this cation exchange capacity reasonably
robust and it was organic matter in the
soil and that plant roots tended like
that so when the organic matter gets
below two percent and one of the things
you would think about recommending to a
grower would be some sort of a cover
crop or your application or something to
boost dead organic matter content
soil test generally report values for
phosphorus potassium calcium and
magnesium we talked about those curves
before there's response curves it's
usually they've been done for these for
macro nutrients and not for the
micronutrients those are the ones you're
going to get results from oftentimes
these micronutrients will be print it
out but they're kind of hard to
interpret the techniques are used to
analyze nutrients are oftentimes
something called an ICP they send the
extractant through that ICP and it
prints out not only the PK calcium
magnesium going to print out everything
else too so it's not unusual to see a
soil testing lab present that values for
zinc and manganese and iron even
aluminum most of the time these aren't
really very useful like we don't use
those for guidance and what to apply to
the soil usually we use these when we
want to try to diagnose a problem like a
toxicity or some sort of an imbalance
but they're typically not used to give
recommendations on those are usually
just pique calcium magnesium and any
sort of ph adjustment not you also might
see ya sorry I didn't mean to interrupt
jeff had a question about pH when you're
finished with what you're discussing
okay
the question is do we assume a natural
reduction in pH over time and therefore
apply lime to maintain a pH in a range
of that over a five-year period we put
so with normal rainfall conditions all
we lose maybe you know 500 pounds of
cations from the typical soil a year so
if you have a lot of calcium in your
soil or potassium and so forth we lose
some of it but it might not be enough to
really knock the pH down even over a
five-year period the time when we have
to worry about that is on sandy soils or
we can't really build up the reserve too
much without pushing the pH too high so
if we puts the ph 2 6.5 and we have a
sandy soil and we get a lot of rain year
after year after year yeah it's too we
could knock the pH down below a
desirable level and then we might have
to go back in and reapply but as I
showed earlier it's really difficult to
do that and something like raspberries
because they might live longer than five
years strawberries you just wait to the
end of their normal life and reapply the
line but on raspberries it's kind of
hard to do that so we want to try to
make sure we get all that in there
before we plant so we don't have to go
back in and try to add later on
I wanted to mention that the nitrates
some soil testing labs n a value for
nitrate but really is so variable almost
from day to day there's not a very
useful guideline for making
recommendations so this lavender doesn't
even print it although they would have
it if you would ask for it the other
value we sometimes ask growers start to
run or make requests for is boron one is
one of those micronutrients that can
have an impact on plant growth and those
values do mean something so we will
recommend it rowers particular your
strawberries and raspberries ask for
boron if it doesn't automatically come
with the test sometimes it does
sometimes it does
this is just a diagram as the different
forms of nitrogen and the different
cycles that are happening within
nitrogen and it's just so variable that
anytime you do a night raider a nitrogen
test of the soil it's just a snapshot in
time it's so dynamic that those numbers
really don't mean anything so we don't
pay much attention to them when we get
them or on any other hand I mentioned is
a an important nutrient it's important
for cell elongation and if you don't
have boron your cells tend not to
elongate very well and so this is a root
of a strawberry plant grown in a
nutrient solution is complete has
everything in it the next slide i'm
going to show you is one where the boron
was removed from the nutrient solution
and you can see how that roots are real
stubby and course a plant without boron
has a difficult time taking up all the
other nutrients that it needs that's why
we want to make sure we have adequate
boron in the soil so you don't get a
situation like this where the soil tests
will show or you got adequate potassium
and phosphorus and magnesium and calcium
but the plants are showing deficiencies
in those values well it might not be too
low potassium or too low of fosters it
might be that your brawn is inadequate
that's why we want to look at that
particular nutrient
gay back to the soil test the other
thing we want to look for is a type of
tests that we've run on this case here
it was modified Morgan but different
labs run different tests so when you get
the values under there they don't really
mean a whole lot if somebody sends me
values of a soil test I don't really
have any basis for knowing what's low
medium and high you have to trust that
the soil testing lab knows what low
medium high is for your particular crop
so here we have recommendations on what
low medium high is and again because
different labs use different methods
different extractions you gotta trust
that they know what they're doing now
and then you get your recommendations
print it out down here based on the soil
test levels above
mentioned you have to have confidence in
the recommendations provided by your lab
the best analysis in the world is
useless without a good recommendation
unfortunately many analytical labs
provide these general plant
recommendations that are good for field
crops they don't really fine-tune them
to the needs of the specific crops that
we might be interested in like
strawberries like raspberries and I
can't tell you how many times I've seen
soil tests come back for blueberries and
the recommendations look like they
should have been for corn something
because the lab is spitting out a
general recommendation for a generic
crop on that soil without understanding
the differences between these perennial
crops and some of the crops that require
a low pH so just a word of warning on
that you've got to trust the lab knows
what they're doing Marvin jeff had a
question on boron is it mobile in the
soil war on is very mobile in the soil
that's one of those nutrients that you
can come in and apply any time of the
year and you can apply it right to the
soil surface even right over the leaves
and it'll wash into the soil and get
taken up by the roots and into the plant
so that's one is fairly easy to correct
even after the plants in the ground it's
not like some of the other nutrients
that are very difficult to move into the
root zone
so let's look at a few examples here and
see what we can come up with this is an
example of a soil test strawberries on a
clay loam soil and we're going to trust
that the lab gives us the right values
for what's low medium high and are
reporting these out medium phosphorus
potassium high calcium low magnesium
boron has more than one pound and pH of
5.2 relatively high are getting there so
what you think a soil test
recommendation might provide for this
particular example give you a second to
look at that maybe you might want to jot
that down somewhere and see what you
come up with
so the first thing I would do without
knowing anything about the lab or the
extractor anything is look at the pH and
I see well it's 5.2 so it's less than
the six or 6.2 265 that we would ideally
want for strawberry so I would know that
some sort of a pH modification is in
line here I also look here and and see
that phosphorus is a little bit low we
might want to raise that a little bit I
also know that a lime contains calcium
but it also contains magnesium now in
this case magnesium is low so one option
I would have in this case and the
recommendation engine should generate
this is when you're recommending a pH
change they might want to recommend high
magnesium line so you can raise the pH
and provide your magnesium in the same
step
so here the recommendation would be da
lama decline because it has high
magnesium and phosphorus
arvin Glenn had a question without n
represented on the soil test what is the
basis for the N recommendation I'm glad
you asked that question the basis for
the nitrogen recommendation is sort of a
ballpark figure of what you would apply
to a crop in that particular year so for
example strawberries a standard
recommendation would be anywhere from 70
to 100 pounds of nitrogen per acre just
based on the age of the plant based on
the crop itself we always have to add
nitrogen every year and that's sort of a
standard so it's not based on the soil
test that nitrogen recommendation is
just sort of a standard practice that a
grower would use the fertilized to put
you in the ballpark we're going to talk
in a couple of weeks about using foliar
analysis and one of the most important
uses of foliar analysis is to adjust
those ballpark nitrogen recommendations
to fit your particular crop situation so
the recommendation might say well an
establish strawberry field you know 100
pounds of nitrogen but we can use that
fuller test to adjust that up or down
based on what the values are in the
leaves will talk about that layer so the
recommendation of nitrogen on a soil
test for a perennial crop is just
ballpark figure this is what you
typically do the first year of the plan
Sonia is commenting that low magnesium
can also be exacerbated by high
potassium because they compete for
uptake correct there is some item you're
some thinking that that can indeed
happen there's competition between these
cations for exchange sites so in soils
that are really really high in one of
the cations and really really low on the
other there is some sense that that hive
cations can suppress the uptake of the
lower level of the cation sins it low
supply so yeah those situations are
pretty rare but they can't happen and
I'm actually going to give you an
example of this in a few minutes dan is
wondering on some of the High Line soils
in San from New York where the pH values
can be closer to seven if an application
of sulfur should be made to lower the pH
for strawberries I would say sure
certainly our target pH would be you
know 6 226 5 for strawberries and if
you're up at seven and you're in a
pre-planned situation I think software
would be appropriate material to apply
to lower that a little bit so that the
nutrient uptake can be improved and you
get less precipitation form between some
of these nutrients that happen at high
ph is where they become unavailable to
the planet
right let's look at a second example
this is blueberries on a sandy loam soil
and we have low calcium we have pH is
just about right high organic matter so
what would we do in a situation here
potassium tide Foster's high magnesium
is high it looks like we need calcium
but the ph is already kind of where we
want it we don't really want to raise a
calcium too much more what we do here
so in this case we might recommend
calcium sulfate instead of line to
provide our calcium because calcium
sulfate doesn't change the pH very much
when it's added so it's a way of
providing counseling without a big
change in pH so again the soil test
recommendation should know that take
into account whenever it makes the
recommendation
oh I see Jeff okay yeah good oh no I
just got to say Jeff had a question
about sulfur yeah exalting strawberries
yeah software is needed by alfalfa but
it's also needed for all other crops as
well so the essential nutrient is part
of amino acids so all plants need sulfur
and in our part of the world software is
rarely limiting it comes down and
rainfall acid rain and there's usually
plenty of software it's rare that you
have to add sulfur for the nutrient
value to the plant we might add sulfur
for the ph adjustment but usually not
for the nutrient value again a software
around it's in the organic matter is
usually we're not in situations here
where we're usually very sulfur
deficient at least not in very crops
take a third example raspberries loamy
soil here were high and everything the
ph is right with the soil test recommend
anything here well it might and this
goes back to what Sonia asked about
earlier sometimes even though we have
high values if we're really super high
in one nutrient one cation particular
they can depress the uptake of the other
two particularly you know calcium
magnesium can interact a little bit
potassium even though it's low here
that's not actually a pretty high value
for potassium but calcium relatives of
magnesium is low that ratio of calcium
magnesium is round so higher than ten
typical soils it would be around five
five times as much calcium and magnesium
so in this case here we actually might
need to recommend a little bit of
magnesium to bring that balance back up
so it wouldn't be unusual for a test
like that to have a little bit of
magnesium sulfate in the recommendation
not so much to change the pH this
doesn't really change the pH but it just
adds a little bit of magnesium in the
soil to bring that ratio into balance
okay example for blueberries sandy loam
soil you can see that we're low on
phosphorus I'm potassium low in calcium
magnesium is medium ph is 5.9 and
organic matters you know pretty low here
so what would you recommend in this case
or what do you think a soil test
recommendation should say
one of the things we would want to do is
try to raise that organic matter a
little bit blueberries like organic
matter 1.3 is really quite low so we
want to do that but the ph is 5 point on
we have to lower that quite a bit and
one of the things we know that about
blueberries is that they don't really
require a whole lot of of some of these
cations they're really good at sucking
that out of the soil so all we might
need to recommend here is just to lower
the pH increase the organic matter and
those other nutrients will probably take
care of themselves because we're
measuring that at a high pH when we
lower the pH the blueberries blueberries
come much more efficient at taking these
nutrients up
so I see a question here about how
strong is the effective added nitrogen
on ph it depends a little bit on your
nitrogen source if you use ammonium
sulfate as a nitrogen source which we
often recommend on blueberries it
acidifies the soil if we use urea it
also acidify the soil a little bit
because it's adding NH 4 plus 2 soil if
we add nitrate to the soil like calcium
nitrate it tends to either be neutral or
raise a pH a little bit so it depends a
little bit on a source of nitrogen is
the impact on ph but ammonium sulfate is
going to have the strongest negative
effect on ph urea somewhere in the
middle your nitrate forms of nitrogen
not much but we wouldn't we use nitrogen
to actually try to affect the pH we
would use it to maybe keep it at a
certain level we wouldn't use say
ammonium sulfate to lower the pH one
unit that would be way too much and the
questions can blueberries use nitrate
they can use nitrate but they don't like
it they're much more preferentially
using ammonium form of a nitrogen and
take that up if you put blueberry roots
in a solution it just has nitrate
available to it the roots will turn
black and a plain old I if you put
blueberries in the field and you apply
nitrate fertilizers to it the bacteria
in the soil under low pH conditions
which you should have of your planting
blueberries anyway will convert that
nitrate into ammonium and where it can
be taken up more readily and used by the
blueberry plant so you get away with it
but nitrate is more leachable and also
ammonium is a better source because it
not only lowers the pH but it's more of
a slow release more available over a
long period of time and blueberries can
take it up directly so that's the
preferable source for blu rays
it is couple more examples here
blueberries clay loam soil were high
medium and phosphorus high potassium
high calcium high magnesium good boron
pH is pretty high organic matter is
pretty high what we recommend here I
wanted to grow blueberries well if we go
back to that chart we looked at before
and we saw a pH up around six and we see
here that the cation exchange capacity
is probably going to be pretty high
because your gang matter is going to be
pretty high we're already high in
calcium magnesium and we don't want a
lot of calcium magnesium in the soil
blueberries don't like calcium in
particular the best recommendation here
is probably just don't grow blueberries
the soil is just not appropriate for
blueberries account of exchange capacity
coupled with the pH is so great that it
would take so much sulfur to lower that
that it probably won't be worth it
economically and that high calcium it's
going to cause problems for years on end
because of that
more strawberries in a sandy soil low
phosphorus low calcium low pH so boron
the organic matter so this soil test is
probably going to come back with several
recommendations calcitic lime because we
were low on calcium phosphorus some
boron and some organic matter
and the final example here raspberries
and loamy soil or medium most things
fairly high in aluminum good boron iph
organic matter now most of the time if
you saw soil test like this you might
say well you know I've got medium values
for most of these things organic matter
is pretty good pH is in the range I
might want it probably don't have to do
too much here but in this case here we
might want to correct that with a small
amount of P and K but we might want to
add a little bit higher rate of lime
then was recommended in soil test and
the reason for that is this aluminum
value is pretty high and that can cause
problems later on and the higher we
raise the pH the less available aluminum
is so we might want to push the pH to
the very high end so that it makes the
aluminum less available to the plant and
aluminum can be toxic that's why we
don't really want it can be toxic so in
this case here the aluminum value is
providing diagnostic information that a
plant to understand maybe why those
plants aren't growing very well or why
what we might want to do to make a
correction before we plan
this is a field of blueberries is a real
situation and the blueberry plants in
this section here I'll weren't grown so
well and the other thing is the grass in
this section wasn't growing so well
either and yet down here at this end the
grass was going pretty well now we took
soil tests from three different places
from plantings there were three
different ages one place the plants look
pretty good the slide was fine ph was
good aluminum phosphorus is okay the
other place the plants look really
pathetic the ph was a little bit higher
than average aluminum was pretty high
plants was pretty sick and there was
dead sod and here this is the
interesting thing the ph is really high
you think blueberries might not do so
well there and they were kind of fair
weren't terrible and sod was living
these plants with a higher pH were a lot
better off than the plants that were
sick and even a lower pH what was going
on here well it appears from the soil
test that in this case here aluminum was
really high and it could be coming toxic
to the blueberry plant and as we raise
the pH even though the aluminum was up a
little bit the higher pH makes that
aluminum unavailable to the plant so the
plants were able to survive a little bit
longer and do better so pH can react and
relate to a lot of different things
looking at these values of some of these
Micronesians can't give you clues
sometime as to how things were working
out there in the soil
last thing the last concept I want to
mention is that this nutrient uptake
occurs through three different ways when
we have nutrients in the soil on direct
contact with roots so the root surface
is actually like almost has direct
contact with the soil and the nutrient
just kind of jumps right across that
membrane mass flow which is nutrients
dissolved in water they get taken into
the plant through the transformational
stream or diffusion and diffusion is
sort of short distance transport of
these nutrients when they dissolve in
water the water actually doesn't move
through the plant like mass flow but the
nutrients diffuse through an aqueous
solution from a level of high
concentration in the soil to a lower
concentration inside the root so there's
three different mechanisms and nutrients
that are primarily taken up by contacted
diffusion must be in close proximity to
the root itself the root on average only
has about 1% and at most three percent
of it of the surface of that root is in
direct contact with the soil so
nutrients have to be thoroughly mixed in
order to be taken up prior to planting
this is up this is with corn but it it's
appropriate for all of our crops this is
the mode of uptake for the various
nutrients based on this route
interception mass flow diffusion and
different nutrients have different modes
basically being taken up into the plant
nitrogen is mostly taken up by mass flow
in other words nitrogen nitrate nitrogen
and ammonia nitrogen didn't get
dissolved in the aqueous solution when a
plant transpires it moves into the root
system and in the water leaves the leaf
leaving the nutrient inside the plant
that's why you can put nitrogen on the
soil surface and it gets down into the
roots because it dissolves in the water
its soluble and it's taken up by mass
flow someone also asked earlier about
boron boron also is very highly soluble
and taken up by mass flow that's why we
can apply boron to the soil surface
against dissolve gets taken up by mass
flow no problem we can apply it after
the plants are established but some of
these other nutrients are mostly taken
up by things like diffusion like oestrus
so it has to be thoroughly incorporated
into the soil it doesn't dissolve very
quickly it doesn't move through the soil
very rapidly so we want to have that
mixed in with the soil before we plant
same way with potassium a lot of
diffusion not that much mass flow so
that's why magnesium calcium not much
diffusion some mass flow some routing
reception but certainly for P and K we
want to make sure we have that mixed in
with the soil very well otherwise the
roots won't be able to take it up these
tables of course are going to be
available to you to download to print
off and down it should be right here in
this website a few days and it gets
posted
now once our plants are established and
you're growing we don't really rely on
the soil test so much we rely on the
soil test to tell us what our pH is but
we don't pay much attention to the
levels of P and K and magnesium and
calcium after that once the plants on
the ground we look using foliar analysis
to make adjustments and we use the pH in
conjunction with the foliar analysis and
that's going to be the subject of an
upcoming webinar next week Eric Hanson's
going to talk about these nutrient
sources and some of the characteristics
of these various nutrient sources that
are out there that you can use in a pre
plant situation to both modify the pH
and add phosphorus potassium magnesium
and so forth in look at it from both the
conventional perspective and a
perspective and over of an organic
grower
so that's what i have for the
presentation and there's a few minutes
left if anybody wants to type in some
questions let's see if they can try to
answer them thanks Marvin
you
I just want to remind everyone that if
you haven't filled out the demographics
questionnaire or the pretest that
they're available down below and you can
email them to me at MCM for at
cornell.edu if you missed either of the
first two webinars there's a link to
them in the archive on the bottom
left-hand side of your screen and as
Marvin indicated dr. Eric Hanson from
Michigan State University will be our
speaker next week
so Jeff asks about organic sources of
nutrients and our characteristics that's
what the entire webinar is going to be
about next week so i will save that for
Eric to talk about
an acceptable boron level generally you
want at least one pound preferably two
pounds that's sort of that ballpark that
we're looking at and fortunately for
boron it's not so dependent on soil test
and it's also most soil testing labs use
a separate extractant for the boron they
use a hot water extract and so they just
put hot water in the soil take it out
run it for boron so the procedure for
looking at boron is fairly standardized
across labs so we can pretty confidently
say between one and two pounds is where
you want to aim for this lesson one
pound you probably have to supplement
and that's going to be a lot more
standard among labs and most of the
other nutrient levels you're going to
get
you
Jeff ass is there a physiological reason
for blueberries aversion to calcium in
nitrate that's a really good question so
blueberries have evolved in these low pH
soils and nutrient levels are very low
in these low pH soil sandy soils wet
soils and they've evolved some
characteristics and enable them to
survive under those conditions and one
of those adaptations is this association
with and the micro riesel fungi that
colonize the roots of blueberries and
then actually help the blueberry
increase the surface area as they go out
and grow through the soil and the
blueberry gives that end of mycorrhizal
fungus some carbohydrate and in return
the fungus pulls in nitrogen and
phosphorus and gives it to the bluray
plan most of the time the nitrogen
that's in the soil is in the ammonium
form of nitrogen and so some people
think because of this in the micro Rifle
Association the fungi prefer it and the
blueberries ended up just evolving a
preference for that because that is the
most available type of nitrogen in low
pH soils and actually when a regular
plant a non blueberry plant takes up
nitrate interestingly enough inside the
plant it converts it into the ammonium
form and moves it around and then rican
verse it into nitrate forms at times
because if you look at amino acids and
all that comprise proteins dirt in the
ammonium form so why I guess maybe a
better question is why other plants I
haven't evolved at an adaptation to take
up ammonium nitrogen since energetically
it's easier to do that than it is to
take up nitrate and then reduce it back
down to ammonium and move it around and
in terms of calcium I'm not exactly sure
why that is I think it has to do with
inside the plant interactions with iron
and somehow it maybe precipitates with
the iron and inhibits it but high
calcium soils and blueberries just don't
go well together even if the pH is love
one of the things we'll recommend in a
soil test if the calcium level is above
a certain amount even if the pH is kind
of close and you can lower it with
software we might recommend look
someplace else this isn't a good soil
for blue eyes you just know historically
high calcium and blueberries don't go
well together
the soil moisture content at the time of
sampling affect soil test results not
really not if you're just looking at the
nutrients because what they'll do when
they get the soil back in is often dry
it down anyway and so whether you send
them dry soil or they comes to the lab
and a dry it before they analyze it
doesn't make a huge difference there is
there's some debate whether there needs
to be moisture correction to soils when
they do the analysis but that has more
to do with some labs scoop soil and some
labs way it and the question is do you
get a different result when you scoop it
or you weigh it or you haven't moussed
or it's dried so it can make a slight
difference not so much qualitatively but
quantitatively but labs have not come to
consensus over whether it needs to be
dried or not most labs do it dry I think
most labs to the dry how do I feel about
ammonium phosphate for blueberry
ammonium phosphate sir if you're low on
phosphorus and you need to fertilize the
plant that would be a good way of
killing two birds one stone it provides
an ammonium a source of nitrogen and it
provides that phosphorus at the same
time
a higher iron content I don't believe to
have a higher higher content than other
plans that's not the case but for some
reason I iron availability seems to
impact blueberries more than aren't
availability and other crops again I'm
not exactly sure why that is maybe
somebody out there knows the answer to
that
thank you very much Marvin I really
appreciate you speaking to us today
again next week our topic is soil
nutrient management and we'll be looking
at correction of soil problems
application technology conventional
nutrient sources organic nutrient
sources lyman moon pH reduction with
Eric Hansen from MSU a couple more
questions Marvin
a availability of calcium sulfate in New
York its gypsum I know that there are
I'm not specifically in New York but
drywall for housing is gypsum and there
are some places that I know are crushing
that to extract the material from within
the drywall and then selling that for
agricultural uses and that's great
source of gypsum and the high iron
content is related to the low pH like
with cranberry yeah it is if you look at
those charts where we looked at the
availability of nutrients with pH you
can see that at the lower end iron
availability goes way up for some reason
you know calcium inside the plant not
outside the plant and soil but inside
the plant has some impact on that
availability of calcium it could have to
do so that they could have to do with
the fact that active iron in the plan is
in the ferric form and maybe with too
much calcium in the planet converts more
today I'm sorry it's in the ferrous form
it converts more to the ferric form so
it goes from FB + 2 which is active
biologically active to Fe plus 3 which
is inactive and calcium may cause the
iron to go from one form together in
which case a leaf analysis will still
show you how iron in a plant because it
doesn't distinguish between the two
types it's just that the type and high
calcium soils is more in that ferric and
active form that's that's my hypothesis
again maybe somebody else knows
alright if there aren't any other
questions
then I think we'll close thank you so
much Marvin for your insights
thank you everyone and we hope you'll
join us all again next week
you